hey everybody listen got some news for
you if you're listening to us on apple
podcast you can no longer subscribe you
gotta follow so i'm gonna ask you that
you would double check and make sure
that you are following us
even if you're still listening just
double check and make sure that you
follow and by the way if you're not
following and if you're not listening
seriously
what's up with that
we're only the hottest science podcast
that there is
i mean that's not even a personal
opinion
all right maybe that is
either way you should be doing it
so just follow us on apple podcast it'll
make me happy it'll make you happy
everybody wins
[Music]
chuck
yes
you heard the expression burn baby burn
um i'm a republican of course
all right i'm sorry i shouldn't have
made that joke but it was for a minute
that was a a a slogan that meant that
they wanted to drill for oil and stuff
like that
drill baby drill but sorry
i apologize and anybody out there i
don't mean anything buy it okay
all right
so burn baby burn just as a as a concept
um i don't know if you ever thought much
about what it is for something to burn
have you um it's a disco party i want to
be at every time that's what it is burn
baby burn this is going to burn
burn baby
mother yeah
all right
so here's the thing i have never thought
really about what it takes for something
to burn except that i know that anything
that outside the presence of oxygen
won't burn okay so burning just in
common usage of the term
means combustion
in the presence of oxygen
okay that's what we generally mean when
we say something is burning okay all
right so that's why for example you
might have done this experiment in maybe
middle school or possibly as early as
elementary school you could take
something and burn take a piece of paper
light it but then put some kind of dome
over it yeah and then it eats up all the
oxygen inside and it just extinguishes
itself right so
it needs the oxygen to burn all right
now
i got a question for you
have you ever burned
water
okay the answer is no just just don't
stop thinking no i want to hear you know
just wait a second just wait a second
because
i know you're an astrophysicist but
maybe i should explain a couple things
to you now
of course i've never burned water
because water doesn't burn
if you can imagine taking a cube of pure
aluminum okay
i cannot but go ahead okay just just
imagine a chunk of aluminum and putting
it on
on the stove
don't put it in the oven okay okay
will it burn
aluminum um in a char
i don't know if it'll burn but also no
we don't think no it just gets hotter
right yeah it gets hot you're not saying
that's why we can make make pans out of
aluminum okay because they don't burn
okay so the point is
notice you'll only use the word burn for
some things and not others
correct in fact normally it's on fire
the things you're most likely to use the
word burn for
are the things that turn black
after they have burned
true
that is true
um basically most things that burn you
know they're black afterwards except
water
except aluminum x i can go down a list
okay
except lead
except there are plenty of things that
can burn that sorry that can get hot not
turn black and we would never say they
were burning
true okay so the question then is
through my cast iron pen
it gets hot as hell
it's sitting on fire actual flame flames
can be on it and it's not burnt never
burns okay okay so
what do all the things that burn have in
common
all the things that burn what it they i
don't know they catch fire i don't know
what they have in common is
you park the curtains
molecularly parked the curtains and you
find the carbon atom i was going to say
carbon but isn't carbon in pretty much
everything it's in everything
you will ever eat
except one thing
except two things salt and water
i knew the salt and i knew the water
yeah have you ever burned salt no you
can't you're right okay this is my point
okay
by the way salt is is is crystals sugar
is crystals you can burn sugar yeah okay
and sugar does it catches fire and it
melts and it melts cats fire burns turns
black the whole thing the whole deal so
so
other than salt
and water everything else you eat
contains the carbon atom deep down
within the molecules right a b the
molecules that contain carbon atom have
in themselves chemical energy
correct yes yes that's why you eat food
at in the first place because you take
get the energy from the food so your
body can use the energy be it a dead
plant or a dead animal i don't care
you're eating it to get in for in large
measure there's some nutrients you're
after too but in large measure you get
in your calories to get the energy that
they have okay so now watch so you have
these molecules that have chemical
energy when you burn it
you're breaking these chemical bonds
with the help of oxygen right and the
act of breaking these bonds releases
energy
your body does that but if you do it
with a flame
all you have to do is start it
it's like a the corner of a piece of
paper and the rest of the paper burns
because the little bit that you started
it breaks the chemical bonds that are
sitting above it which
causes a chain reaction a chain reaction
all the way up all the way on up
and so
when you and by the way wood
campfire
the wood park the curtains there's the
carbon atom in there right and wood
contains all the energy that it had
pulled out of the environment to become
a tree in the first place that's right
then you cut it down oh by the way
what kind of wood burns best well it's
got to be dry dry wood
why because you can't burn water right
and the worst thing in the world
is to have dry wood
with a wet spot inside of it
and then while it's burning
it says
hey
and you're
i didn't know what's talking to me it's
actually it's a word it's speaking
english it starts speaking man
what the [ __ ] are you doing exactly
man what's wrong with you
what's wrong
right because a little pocket of water
it's not going to burn all we'll do is
get hotter become steam expand and
pop right pop
so that's why you want to dry out the
wood get all the water out of there so
that it's just these
fat carbon molecules waiting for you to
extract the energy from them and make
the beautiful fire in the fireplace
and so depending on the chemical
reactions depending on how efficient or
inefficient they are you can leave
behind layers of carbon
and that's what we basically call soot
right
soot by the way it's possible to burn
something so there's no soot left over
because then the carbon gets up took
into other molecules that are stable and
float away like co2 okay so carbon
dioxide is a product of burning wood and
other things and that's not carbon left
that turns black that's just a whole
other molecule that's transparent and
you can't smell it you can't taste it
and it's in the atmosphere but if you
have certain kinds of combustion certain
kinds of burning that don't
successfully turn it all into gas you'll
get a residue at the bottom and there is
carbon ash and it's carbon you're
revealing the carbon out of which all of
life is based look at that
that's pretty doggone cool
so whenever you have a fire it's
basically the circle of life this is
exactly so you should hold that wood up
too
[Laughter]
due respect for the tree that gave its
life for the molecular energy contained
in it and the fact that life is carbon
based yes
you know what that is that is very
poetic actually it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful thought i love it and the co2
you just put into the air that's not
contributing to global warming because
the tree took it out in the first place
right so
you are carbon neutral in the process
you are carbon neutral provided you're
not only just cutting down trees to feed
your fireplace you got to make sure the
tree is planted somewhere and you're
basically carbon neutral carbon dioxide
neutral in that exercise so there you
have it kumbaya around the fireplace i
love it i love it
i'm gonna go burn
[Laughter]
just think about it because we always
historically made houses out of wood
right and wood is basically fuel
that's
building your house out of fuel and
you're surprised it burns down right
right cavemen never had house fires no
never
and the brick house the pig lives in the
brick house nobody's burning down his
house right exactly okay that's super
cool man
all right we got to call it quits there
all right
explainer video chuck always good to
have you always a pleasure neil degrasse
tyson as always keep
[Music]